hello rejects Greg Halleck hear how the
halma ha
this is a walnut for now not a boyo is
from the channel sweet eats make sure to
go to that channel when you get the
chance after this video before we do
that mo net is also an actress and she
writes see you she even put out a short
film on YouTube that was wonderful you
guys could go check it out you know I'm
going to tag that short film in this
video you guys gotta go watch it it's
really well done serious go watch that
[ __ ] anywho we both like film so we're
gonna do a trailer review real fast a
lot of people when I say a lot of people
I mean a lot so much to the point that
I'm gonna go into my phone and
specifically name someone who has been
harassing me to do a review of this
trailer reason why I haven't is because
I saw Rotten Tomatoes that this film was
getting horrible feedback am I mention
that the studio especially won't let me
monetize this video so this is gonna
make no money my saying that Studios
work with reactions people jeremy bokor
here's what he said today out of all the
day she's commented
look man i watch a lot of your videos
that's what he sounds like
i enjoy them you make me laugh and I
respect your opinion I'm gonna ask you
again
can you please react to the man down
trailer I'll keep asking till the movie
comes out if I have to ha ha well buddy
Politis harassment well it's just like
if I was to text you every day and you
were ignoring me every call you every
day and I was nice doesn't mean it's not
harassment true but it could be worse it
could be worse I believe in persistence
wears down resistance calling her my
turning sad sad that's why Shia some
disturbing violence
we got these my battle buddy kicked the
doors ago took getting fired she's not a
relationship you understand if you
haven't been through it I guess is there
a reason y'all don't want to discuss
what you saw in there
really variety huh really Friday I can't
take it back look at one that got bad
reviews I know right it's kind of
surprising so Scott surprised Mike my
contacts funny all right quality yeah
after a reaction when I cry it only
comes out this left eye doesn't that
mean something like when you tear out of
one side it's from happiness on the
other side it's from sadness or
something I thought you cried on your
left I only that means you're gonna burn
in hell
start getting that right I ready I love
Shia LaBeouf do you yeah I have Shia
oh yeah I do I do that
wow I didn't know that yeah have you
seen Fury yes I have seen he's pretty
good in that he's great
yes but have you seen holes yeah yes
that's another good one also great in
that even Stevens even Stevens even
better I would say than any of his most
recent work that's when he was at his
prime yeah so he also did this other
movie and I can't remember what it's
called it wasn't one of his bigger
movies but it's basically like ham
chasing a girl around and it ends up
with him like I won't tell you the
ending never mind I'm not gonna that
goes that went nowhere
but anyway it's great he's really cool
see I'm a nymphomaniac no I have not
seen that yet it had like - do you see
his penis in that you see his penis in
nymphomaniac a couple of times well
honey and that's one of the movies he
had real sex with someone in oh right I
think you would like it I think you
would I mean come on I heard your song
that you did if you saw Shia LaBeouf's
peanuts that of you
without giving away your song won't easy
any that looks good it looks good okay
I'm kind of conflicted with Shia LaBeouf
honestly sometimes I think he is amazing
other times I'm like this guy takes
himself very like there are times where
it's like he seems like he's kind of
overdoing it the drop dramatic aspects
of the life where he kind of loses other
layers of a character he just gets so
caught up in this serious but that could
work for this role oh yeah I think for a
role like this it was yeah for a
traumatized war vet absolutely that
could totally work it looks like he does
a great job how old is he now I think
he's 16 officially he's very talented
he's one of the few Disney stars that
have actually broken out of the Disney
yes him and David Henry from back in the
day he was like crying like an every
other scene in this trailer and pretty
much every other movie he's done yeah
the mark of a good actor if he can cry I
think he's great he really feels like he
genuinely feels everything that he's
going through it's not just going
through the motions and you know it
creates a whole character and I love his
I love his weird antics that he's sort
of developed over the years like I like
crazy Shia LaBeouf I like him wearing a
bag over his head I like him saying yeah
I'm gonna sit still while you come in
the room doing the [ __ ] you want to me
I'm just gonna take it that's cool I'm
like you're weird artists I did hear he
had sex with a girl while he was while
he had a girlfriend at the time though
but he's like I didn't do that's part of
the that's part of the Act though is
they're allowed to do whatever they want
with me
I wonder if you like showered after
every guess or if you just kept it going
like it's kind of dangerous I like crazy
Shia I like crazy shot and crazy Shia
here looks like a good job I mean my
only issue with it this looks like one
of those films that would probably only
be worth it
from Shia LaBeouf's performance like you
got cool actors here like gary oldman
and kate mara and Jai Courtney looks
alright I guess but the rest of the film
kind of looks like it looks a little
stereotypical I mean that's not to be an
insults of war vets after a while there
it becomes a serving kind of genre
becomes a certain kind of film and
something about it this seemed to really
offer anything super fresh I feel like
it might be a weaker storytelling movie
but I feel like Shia would probably
still give a great job even if the
movies weak I feel like he'd still be
strong I see what you're saying yeah so
it's no disrespect to Shia do a good job
yeah I just feel like it looks a little
repetitive the tone of it seems a little
confusing to what's going rods man I'm
just gonna say what they're saying
that's what this videos this original
content on providing is gonna be mages
saying what other critics are saying
zero percent out of eight critics so far
LaBeouf's the booth performance is
overpowered by the film's grandiose
misplaced ambition to switch back and
forth between genres yeah okay Hollywood
Reporter I don't you ever saw that had
0% a long time I haven't looked at any
of these that was kind of my worries
from watching the trailer it was like
this seems a little bit like totally
confused like I said earlier an
appallingly manipulative cycle but this
is from Variety are you manipulative
it's like what Trump did with Michael
Moore I don't know you guys know this
but he's like retweeted a thing about
Michael Moore acting like Michael Moore
was supporting him but he only took that
first part cuz the rest of it is all
followed by white he thinks Donald Trump
would be a horrible president but I
heard that I was like oh that's kind of
like movie trailers when they take like
a good part of a terrible review yeah
can they put it on there yeah
there's a variety says here an
appallingly manipulative psychological
thriller there this videos not gonna be
mom says which scolds audiences for not
caring enough about our veterans while
counting on the well-meaning message to
excuse us
otherwise awfulness I don't base like my
opinions off of what like other critics
are saying I said there been playing
times where I completely disagree with a
low score rotten
however with that being said a lot of
these people are saying things that I
was kind of thinking like in cliches
all-too-familiar
I don't know you looked it up you look a
little sad I just a little disappointed
no I know you wanted to do well yeah I
know he said he's had a tough lately
hasn't really had any hits lately she's
got to pick a different genre maybe
maybe he needs to stop doing crazy [ __ ]
so much yeah before he did all the bag
over his head and stuff he was getting
like duis and everything shiny get your
personal life under control that was
great good timing Mona on that now
subscribe today rejects and get accepted
Mona Moyo is part of the awesome a
healthy baking channel sweet eats where
you learn how to bake deliciously all of
them on instagram as well you have a
great night America